Hey look mom I'm studying Yiddish so I
can talk to grandma good day guys this
is just a quick video to answer a
question that I got and I decided to
make it into a video because I've had
this question before and maybe it's
something that a lot of people are
wondering the question is are Hebrew and
Yiddish similar or are see blue and
Yiddish kind of the same language the
answer to that is no they are different
languages they're often confused with
each other because the Yiddish language
is written in the Hebrew alphabet in the
same way that Farsi or odoo are written
in the Arabic alphabet or that German is
written in the Roman alphabet just like
English is so someone who doesn't read
that script might look at it and think
that it's the same language but Hebrew
and Yiddish are different another reason
they might be confused is that they are
both related to Jewish people but
they're related to Jewish people in
different ways so Hebrew is the old
language of the Bible of the Old
Testament or the Hebrew Bible as they
would call it the Torah and it's also
been a literary language of Jews
throughout the centuries often for
religious purposes or literary reasons
they would write in Hebrew but it was
just a literary language for a long time
it died as a spoken language but Yiddish
was spoken by Jews in Europe and it's
the language that's mostly related to is
German it's it's kind of a medieval form
of German but I understand that to some
extent Yiddish speakers can communicate
with German speakers and they can
understand each other not fully but to
some extent so it's mostly related to
German but it's been influenced by
Hebrew in terms of vocabulary and also
by Aramaic and maybe some other
languages too because Hebrew and Aramaic
were Jewish literary languages so there
is some Hebrew vocabulary in it but I
think the pronunciation has kind of been
changed and more germanized so it
doesn't sound like Hebrew so much so
Yiddish was influenced by Hebrew to some
extent though and also modern Hebrew was
influenced by
Yiddish because the original Zionists
who came to Palestine to create a Jewish
state they were Yiddish speakers I think
you dish maybe Russian or whatever but
their native languages like Yiddish and
maybe also Russian and others influenced
modern Hebrew so people say that modern
Hebrew syntax and phonology reflects the
Yiddish language to some extent so
Yiddish has influenced modern Hebrew as
well but basically they're separate
languages and you can't communicate with
someone who speaks the other it would be
easier for a you to speaker to
communicate with someone who's big to
German I think all right so hopefully
that is helpful and just quick the
answer to that question all right talk
to you later